wir müssen uns auf 3 45 jahre der
knappheit einstellen das ist der
dramatische satz vom finanzminister
christian lindner seine warnung vor der
großen krise gleichzeitig aber
traumhochzeit mit kanzler und minister
als gäste und mit polizisten
sicherheitskräften die diese hochzeit
auf sylt schützen müssten klar auf
unsere kosten steuerzahlerkosten nach
und fragen die einen man wird ja wohl in
deutschland noch heiraten dürfen oder ja
sagen die anderen aber doch nicht so
gerade jetzt auf kosten der steuerzahler
der große zoff um die traumhochzeit
ein paar wie aus dem bilderbuch
finanzminister christian lindner und
polit journalisten frank ali fällt am
kommenden wochenende werden sich beide
auf der promi-insel der deutschen das
jawort geben auf sylt es könnte alles so
schön sein wenn es nicht diesen herrn
gebe der einen ordentlichen schuss
nordseewasser in den teuren
hochzeitsfeier kippt
eins ist ganz klar die aktuelle krise
wird nicht in wenigen monaten vorüber
gehen ich habe ja schon sehr früh von
einer zeitenwende gesprochen um die es
jetzt hier geht wenn auf sylt die
hochzeitsglocken läuten dann klingelt es
gleichzeitig in der kasse der
gastronomen auf der speisekarte stehen
unter anderem schulter see aus dann und
natürlich champagner luxus pur für die
illustren gäste
denn gefeiert wird unter anderem im
promi treff nummer eins der sansibar
direkt in den dünen und weil man ja
schließlich nicht jeden tag heiratet
darf es gerne auch ein wenig mehr sein
mehr promis rund 140 gäste aus politik
und gesellschaft mehr luxus ein fünf
sterne hotel für rund 600 euro die nacht
so viel genuss seit dem liebespaar
gegönnt zahlen sie ja schließlich selbst
aber da steckt noch mehr drin und
kompost unserer tage gerade auch
politiker sind es ja gewohnt dass sie
durch die gegend chauffiert werden also
sie haben alle ihre fahrer die am alle
ihre limousinen und das muss natürlich
dann auch bei einer hochzeit bei einem
solchen event gewährleistet sein dass
das ist ein riesenaufwand alle von zu
hause vom flughafen von der bahnstation
dann ins hotel zu chauffieren und
natürlich bei der hochzeit dann auch zu
den verschiedenen locations zum
standesamt also zum museum und zur
kirche und zurück das zweite große thema
ist natürlich security also die
sicherheit
deswegen konnte auch die hochzeit
angeblich nicht in italien stattfinden
weil dann nicht für seine sicherheit
gewährleistet werden konnte
die haben alle bodyguards und natürlich
die gäste auch also sind die zuweilen
die höchsten politiker deutschlands und
die müssen natürlich geschützt werden
und danach muss dann auch die location
ausgesucht werden dass die eben auch
wirklich ja beobachtet werden kann dass
es da möglichst nur einen zugang gibt
und dass sie richtig abgeschirmt werden
kann logisch wenn der finanzminister
unter anderem den bundeskanzler zur
hochzeit einlädt wird der luftraum war
süd gesichert und der personenschutz der
polit promis reist von berlin das gibt
es nun mal nicht zum nulltarif und das
löst nicht nur bei den bewohnern der
promi insel sylt sondern in der ganzen
republik eine debatte aus die location
ist natürlich schon gut aber der kann
man sich fragen was ist eine normale
heiratet also es ist schon immer so ein
bisschen schwierig vielleicht gerade in
den jetzigen zeiten vielleicht ein
falsches signal an die menschen das
kommt nicht gut an beweisen beim
allgemeinen folgerichtig da haben wir
uns auch gesagt muss er zahlen ich hätte
gerne um rufe die hochzeit zu sehen ja
also das
und schon
könnt ja also für für den finanzminister
in der aktuellen situation sehr
unpassend muss man sagen und gerade in
der jetzigen situation wo ja wo man eben
nicht mehr weiß wie man eigentlich die
ganzen nebenkosten die so anfallen
zahlen soll ist das glaube ich ein
richtiges zeichen es sei ihm gegönnt
also der macht viel für seinen für
seinen job für sein land warum warum
nicht ganz ehrlich gesagt ich finde es
scheiße die sagen zu uns hier so
schnell und so weiter und so fort und
die kommen mit so was das ist ja nicht
ganz so wie ich wünsche ihm alles gute
und nicht nur ihm sondern seiner frau
auch seiner ehefrau das ist er also der
zoff um die traumhochzeit vom
finanzminister von christian lindner der
zoff zwischen geld und liebe bei uns im
studio hirscher nina kirsch unsere bild
live show chefin der zoff um geld oder
liebe mit welchen augen guckst du auf
diese traumhochzeit ich bin
grundsätzlich immer team liebe das ist
einfach klar so sollen die zuhörer die
sollen heiraten zumal ich muss aber
fairerweise sagen sie haben ja die
hochzeit schon verlegt aus der toskana
sie wollten eigentlich in der toskana
heiraten nach sylt genau aus den gründen
weil es halt einfach zu viel aufwand
gewesen wäre zu teuer da in italien dann
auch noch für die sicherheit zu sorgen
das heißt sie haben schon einen schritt
runtergeschraubt und haben sind aus
ihrem traumland in italien nach süd
gegangen auch ihre lieblingsinsel und
ich finde irgendwann muss man dann auch
mal sagen man heiratet auch nur einmal
im leben gut christina war schon mal
verheiratet aber für frankreich ist es
die erste hochzeit und dass man da
vielleicht auch einen besonderen tag
verbringen möchte ist ganz klar und wenn
olaf scholz da bedenken hat dann soll er
halt nicht kommen dann muss er halt
sagen gut dann sprich zumindest den part
der auf meine kosten geht und dann soll
er doch mit seinem publikum zu hause
bleiben